[Music]
okay uh i'm really excited today
everybody because i am joined by
eli goray aka cassius clay aka mohammed
ali
and before i jump in this interview
anyone watching we're going to be
talking some spoilers about the film
so make sure you watch one night miami
first and then come back to this
eli how you doing today man i'm doing
great how are you doing steve
dude i'm doing so good i'm so excited to
talk to you not only i'm like
a huge muhammad ali fan but to see
someone pull it off
so well makes me now a huge fan of you
as an actor and
it's really exciting and i think what
blew me away the most about your
performance
is the physical aspect of it how hard of
a physical performance it is to take on
muhammad ali so can you kind of go a
little bit into the process especially
in like scenes when you're playing him
in the ring
yeah yeah that was a lot of preparation
and definitely challenging but worth it
um you know i had to gain quite a bit of
weight um i went from 190 to about 220
and uh i had to also learn how to you
know move like him and stay graceful and
and stay
quick and agile because that's what he
was known for as an athlete so
i had a great uh team of fight
coordinators and trainers
who really helped me develop everything
i needed to develop and it just took a
lot of time and
hard work and dedication as they say
yeah and it's interesting i feel like
you taking on that role you know it's
going to be something physical but i
feel like
you're taking on a role of someone who
is embodies confidence
and i wonder does eli in your own life
have that confidence or do you feel like
you had to reach to get there of a
character like
cash's clinic i mean i feel like we're
very different personalities i think i'm
very confident in the things that i
feel like i'm i'm you know like i'm able
to do
but at the same time he's more of an
extrovert and i'm more of an introvert
personality
so i think it just comes out in
different ways but i definitely learned
a lot
from him and from studying him and just
seeing how he approached different
challenges
um it definitely taught me a lot about
just how to overcome situations
so you're telling me eli is doing better
than muhammad ali would do in a pandemic
with the introvert
aspect to it yeah it was interesting
because as an actor in l.a like you
spend like 80
of your day just in the house reading
scripts and like stuff like
that anyway so there was a obviously a
transition but um
i think it was probably a lot different
for most people that have nine to fives
and i'm sure for you too working in the
youtube space you spend a lot of time
editing on your computer a lot of time
in front of your camera so
uh it was a little bit easier transition
totally
um i think it's interesting too about
your character in this film and where he
is in the whole ensemble is like i took
him as a lot of lightness to the film
and
i would say more of the comic relief in
many scenes and
i wondered with working with regina king
who's also
an actor did you did she let you guys
improvise at all or you guys really
stick into the script with a lot of that
um well yeah i mean i think you're right
first of all like i did have a lot of a
lot of the comic relief
uh in some of those scenes which made it
almost uh
a bit of a challenge to try and find the
balance because i also had some very
dramatic and and grounded and intense
scenes um i had
you know the fight scenes which were
kind of action-packed so there was a lot
of range that had to kind of
be covered in the character and so i
really you know regina was instrumental
in helping me
um find the different notes and ground
the different scenes in a way that was
realistic and authentic and didn't come
across as uh
as as impersonation or anything like
that um
but uh in terms of the improving and the
ad living yeah i was i had a lot more
free range i think than the other guys
everyone had quite a bit of free range
but i think my character just had more
opportunities
uh given the personality type in the
given moments where if there was a
something i could say or something that
popped out at me i i felt very confident
and free to be able to just throw it out
there and
they used a lot of it was it
intimidating to have someone like regina
king as a director knowing she's like
this amazing actress did that kind of
how was that it was it was really
amazing i mean she was so supportive
um she saw everything anything that you
did that was kind of like a habit or a
tell as an actor um she would pick up on
those things right away and kind of say
you know you don't need to do that
you can just listen and the script and
the dialogue is
uh of such a quality that it it'll
have its own naturally created um
special moments you don't have to try to
force anything and so it was really
uh really freeing and very um beneficial
to have her there for sure
that's really awesome to hear and i
think i want to ask you too i think that
was on my mind the most after the
watching the film was trying to look at
what
uh cassius clay's main motivation in
this film was and to me
i feel like he was a big part of the
glue holding everyone to get together
and
i was gonna ask you what do you think he
valued the most was it friendship was it
power like he was talking about where do
you think his head was at most of this
story
i mean i think yeah cassius definitely
sets the table and
um you know then kingsley kind of cooks
the meal and
leslie and uh jim clinton uh
i i think his head was just in a place
of realizing that we're stronger
together
than we are divided um as a people
and just as humanity i think that's
where cassius's head was always
at and he recognized that we could be
different
and we could have different viewpoints
and we could even um live
different lives and stay in different
places in different communities and
there was nothing wrong with that but
that we're still all one people
um and and realizing the commonalities
um
as more important than the the
separations i think was
a big part of cassius's walk and his
life and his legacy
yeah for sure and you portray that so
well and
i i want to ask too because there's
oscar buzz with this film
i saw on twitter you retweeted someone
from the ali family said they watched
the film and
just tell me what that's like
experiencing this right now are you on
like this
euphoric kind of trail it was crazy
because i wasn't even looking
for anything to do with one night in
miami i was on twitter i'm a huge boxing
fan
and so i was clarisha shields and then
clarissa clarissa had called out
layla for a fight and i was kind of
following that saga it was like maybe
10 months ago and it i was kind of
catching up on it
and then i saw that she she called out
one night in miami i was like oh
you know like immediately was like
thinking like what am i going to write
back you know i wanted to
you know i don't want to waste her time
or take up her time but it was just it
was really cool to see that uh that she
actually appreciated it and had and was
watching it and
um you know that legacy is just so
powerful and her life in her own right
has been so amazing it was really cool
to see that
yeah that's that's really cool just to
as a fan is like seeing that you got
that honor totally deserved
and it made me happy as well uh eli
thank you so much for joining me today
before i let you go is there anything
else you want to promote besides one
night man miami
um you know i'm in a film called the
guilty with jake gyllenhaal
uh directed by antoine fuqua next year
but really we just want as many people
as possible to go on amazon
to check out one night in miami and and
hit me up on social media
at the real eli goray um you can find me
on instagram and
i love to interact with people awesome
you heard it from the man himself eli
thank you so much and i wish you the
best of luck with award seasons i would
definitely be rooting for you
thank you steve all the best brother god
bless stay safe take care